the Democrats officially take control of
the Congress and the government remains
partially shut down and everything feels
exactly the same hmm what should that
tell us about congressional Republicans
and the federal government we will
analyze then the first two Muslim women
elected to Congress take the oath of
office on a Quran belonging to Thomas
Jefferson apparently they didn't read
the terrifying things Thomas Jefferson
wrote about Islam New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo makes in early 2020
presidential endorsement and abortion
activist defends killing children to
children and finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
oh the horror the horror of everything
being exactly the way it was a month or
two ago we will get to all of the
radical sameness but first let's make a
little money honey with Express VPN with
all the recent news about online
security breaches it is hard not to
worry about where my data goes making an
online purchase
we're simply accessing your email could
put your private information at risk
everybody is watching it if you're
watching this show something tells me
you watch pretty weird stuff on the
internet you don't want that to get out
do you you need to take your privacy
back with express VPN I love it
it has easy-to-use apps that run
seamlessly in the background of my
computer phone and tablet turn on
expressvpn it just takes one click and
you're protected it secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP s IP address rather protecting
yourself with expressvpn costs less than
seven dollars a month and then people
won't know that you visit weird crazy
wild web sites such as daily wire comm
you can get your three months free at
expressvpn comm slash michael mi CH AE l
that's e XP or e SS VPN comm slash
michael mi CH AE l for three months
three with a one-year package expressvpn
accom slash michael to learn more oh wow
what a crazy start to the new year isn't
it everything's different the federal
government is shut down the Democrats
just took control of the Congress and
nothing feels different at all does it
does it this is the very good news this
is a wonderful thing to find out what
has changed in this government shutdown
I was actually thinking I woke up today
I asked sweet little ELISA so what
should I talk about today on the show
what's what's big in the news she said
Mac you should do the government
shutdown and I said well I would except
there's nothing to talk about what is
that what has changed in your life
during this government shutdown it's
what what first of all it's not a full
government shutdown only part of the
government is shut down but here's
what's shutdown the IRS is partially
shut down is that is anybody shedding a
tear for the IRS
being partially shut down as we approach
tax season I don't think so the EPA is
partially shut down so now I don't know
that delta smelt might not be able to
get their spa treatments every week
they'll only be able to get them every
month except that's not even true
because the states are funding
environmental protection as well I can't
really name anything else that's
actually shut down is our military shut
down no of course not is law enforcement
shut down no of course not is what is
what is being shut down our our
embassies shutting down around the world
know what is remaining open Social
Security Medicare Medicaid biggest
drivers of our debt and deficit biggest
portion of the federal budget all remain
open the thing that actually could drive
people crazy if senior citizens were not
able to get their Social Security checks
then maybe you would see a political
push to end the shutdown but not gonna
happen
the mulher investigation remains open if
we're gonna shut down the government
shouldn't we shut down the Muller
investigation maybe then though that
would be pretty motivating for half of
the country air traffic control I was
just flying all around the country
between Christmas and New Year and all
of that I had my TSA PreCheck shut down
one time for one flight and frankly it
was enough to get me on the phone to
call President Trump and say do it cave
I don't care about the wall let me get
my pre check other than that
everything's running fine air traffic
control all the flights are going great
veteran benefits veterans are still
getting all of their benefits food
stamps remains open child nutrition
programs remain open even Native
American food subsidies for reservations
all remaining open the Violence Against
Women Act expired during the government
shutdown this was a big they thought
this was going to be a big political
issue on the left even those programs
are still funded even the thing expired
they're still all being funded through
the Justice Department through Health
and Human Services the shutdown isn't
changing anything it doesn't matter and
therefore the longer this shutdown goes
on the better why cuz what are the
headlight there's no headline about the
shutdown but what we can say we can
point to this shutdown and say look
such-and-such percent of the federal
government was shut down for weeks I
don't know maybe a month maybe a month
and a half and nothing about your life
changed this is what Ronald
was talking about when he said that you
will never you'll always be surprised at
how much government you won't miss you
could lose 30 40 percent of the federal
government you wouldn't miss it at all
you could fire half of the bureaucrats
in this country you would miss no
government there's no suffering to this
shutdown you know Barack Obama when he
shut down the government during his
administration he tried to make it
really mean he tried to make it really
hurt he would shut down veterans
memorials just as veterans groups were
trying to see them he was really trying
to make it painful
national parks largely are not shut down
right now they still have some funding
people are still working some with that
pace and with pay it's fine it's going
just fine keep this shutdown going on
even if we get the border wall funding
keep it keep it shut down this is going
just fine and it underlines this very
important conservative position which is
that all of this government that the
left tells us without this bureaucrat
without this agency the country will
fall apart children will starve people
will die nope no no just shut it down
it's all fine life is going on just fine
maybe we can make you know we always
talk about making tax cuts permanent
making this law firm maybe we can make
this per this partial government
shutdown permanent thing would go a long
way to advancing our agenda maybe that's
the for DHS the President Trump has been
paying playing rather all along the
other big news the other shocking news
of the day the Democrats officially
retake Congress oh here we go Nancy
Pelosi rising up becoming the new
Speaker of the House the blue wave it
was really sort of a purple puddle but
never mind that they are taking the
Congress and nothing's going to change
nothing's going to change what could
change right now one representative Brad
Sherman is making moves to file articles
of impeachment on day one that's cute
he's not even gonna get Democrats in the
house to support that not yet not before
the Muller investigation is over and
even if they did magically get all the
Democrats to vote to impeach which they
won't get to do at least in the near
future they still wouldn't get a
conviction in the Senate so none of that
will change it's just a grandstanding
Democrat making a fool of himself fine
by me nothing nothing new about that
what will happen now is
result of the Democrats having the
Congress we won't get more tax cuts
probably frankly though maybe we will
get some tax cuts Barack Obama was able
to cut certain taxes or maintain certain
tax cuts for people although he did
raise taxes on others we won't get
entitlement reform that's true but we
were never gonna get entitlement reform
anyway president Trump has made it a key
aspect of his platform that he wasn't
going to touch Social Security wasn't
going to touch Medicare or Medicaid so
that I think was probably always more of
a pipe dream for conservatives what what
legislative accomplishments that we
could have gotten are we not going to
get now we're gonna repeal Obamacare we
had our chance to repeal Obamacare and
John McCain shut it down
so a nominally Republican senator voted
to kill Obamacare repeal didn't get that
are we gonna get the wall we had the
house and the Senate for two years we
didn't get the wall maybe we'll try to
get some wall funding now because of
this government shutdown but the
Democrats taking the Congress that
doesn't change anything actually one of
the few major pieces of legislation we
were able to get through when we had the
unified government was letting a bunch
of prisoners out of prison that was the
big the first step act this was major
legislation signed into law there passed
rather just before this government
shutdown
whoop-dee-doo great oh I'm so glad we
elected a conservative Republican and we
elected Republican Congressmen so that
we can let a lot of prisoners out of
prison that's what we want that's the
number one on the conservative agenda
let a bunch of criminals out of prison
great ok good I'm glad I hope and that
was also by the way a bipartisan law so
we'll get that anyway
unfortunately what changes though so if
the legislative stuff doesn't matter
President Trump all of the good
governance he's given us which is
excellent governments and much better
than most of his predecessors oh all of
that was from the executive that was
from judicial appointments aided by
Mitch McConnell in the Senate that was
on issues of foreign policy that was on
issues of the executive bureaucracy and
the executive agencies so ok we lost one
house of the Congress what do you do ok
that's fine now though President Trump
has an adversary
now President Trump has Nancy Pelosi
this is pretty good when Donald Trump
has total control of everything and no
one's fighting him he does fine he's
okay at maneuvering but he really shines
his best moments or when he has an
adversary you know just today after at
Liz Warren announced her exploratory
committee to run for president yesterday
or two days ago rather was it don't
might have even been earlier than that
oh gosh all the days are running
together but we covered it at least
yesterday president Trump sent out this
tweet today which was the meme that we
at the Daily wire came up with of
Elizabeth Warren's campaign and it says
1/20 20th and the president Trump
tweeted that out with our little daily
wire watermark on it which was just
terrific
excellent job mr. president that is when
he shines he shines when he has an
adversary that he can just pummel into
the ground like Jeb Bush or Marco Rubio
unfortunately Ted Cruz Hillary Clinton
he's just he really shines when he's got
an adversary and he's gonna have one now
in Nancy Pelosi good okay fine if it
does it means we don't lose that much on
the legislative side but maybe we pick
up a little bit more in exuberance and
looking forward to 2020 that's a win for
me there is something new in that we now
have the first to Muslim Congress women
being sworn into office and this is
being heralded by the left as such a
wonderful moment because the left loves
Islam the left doesn't know anything
about Islam the Islamic religion opposes
essentially so many tenets of the
interests of intersectional left but
they don't care because they view Islam
as contrary to Western civilization and
they view themselves as contrary to
Western civilization and so they will
unite in an intersectional hierarchy to
oppose intersectional civilization their
part in Western civilization the man the
straight cisgendered white male whatever
the guy with the mustache they're going
to oppose Big Daddy and this is why
they're heralding this these two Muslim
congresswoman Alon Omar and a Rashida at
slab are now being sworn in on a Quran
it was owned by Thomas Jefferson and the
left loves this they think oh yes
all those Christian Americans they think
of the founding fathers as Christian or
Deus tick but really Jefferson owned a
Koran haha you see how about that Islam
is just as essential to the American
Founding as Christianity now the of
course the left doesn't know anything
about history so the irony here is
really enjoyable and very glad that
these two Congress women were sworn in
on Thomas Jefferson's Koran because
Thomas Jefferson had his Quran to learn
about the Islamic religion which was our
first war when he was president our
first war as a country was against the
Barbary pirates against Islamic States
and it was because they were seizing our
ships and seizing our goods and seizing
our sailors so in 1801 the just before
President Jefferson ascended into power
the Congress gave him the authority to
wage war and to attack these Barbary
pirates and then he went in and sent
ships and to stop them and he refused to
pay tribute to the Barbary pirates and
his comments about the Quran he could
not be more explicit he wrote to John
Jay quote it was written in their Koran
that all nations who should not have
answered their Authority were sinners
that it was their right and duty to make
war upon them whenever they could be
found and to make slaves of all they
could take as prisoners and that every
muzzle 'men were Muslim who should be
slain in battle was sure to go to
paradise
fair enough ok that's true so he has
these notes written down and and
actually even at the founding of our
country Christopher Hitchens pointed
this out in an excellent essay for City
Journal in 2007 at the earliest moments
of our country Thomas Jefferson in the
first draft of the Declaration of
Independence wrote he condemned the
slave trade and quote the Christian King
of Great Britain for engaging in this
piratical warfare the opprobrium of
infidel powers he condemned the slave
trade in this early draft of the
declaration of independence for not for
being unchristian and for a was
condemning the hypocrisy of the
Christian King George the third
comparing it to the slave trade which
continues to exists ratha Muslim world
and which certainly existed at that time
and which existed for a millennium
before that this is the actual founding
history this is the founding history
that you see in that Quran owned by
Thomas Jefferson which the left is now
ting to swear in the first two Muslim
Congress women unless you think I'm
Islamophobic I would never want to be
accused of being Islamophobic I actually
don't know what that word means
but if someone could tell me what it
means even if they can't I don't want to
be accused of it these people are quite
radical Ilan Omar and Rashida tribe Ilan
Omar this new Minnesota representative a
tweeted quote
yes Israel has hypnotized the world may
Allah awaken the people and help them
see the evil doings of Israel hashtag
Gaza hashtag Palestine hashtag Israel
she tweeted this in 2014 during a
particularly hot moment of Israel's
hostilities with Hamas Hamas a terrorist
organization she supports the boycott
divest and sanction movement against
Israel she wants to starve Israel cut it
off from the rest of the world and
prevent it from continuing in in the
international order as a state how does
the New York Times react to these women
The New York Times writes quote that the
election of Ilan Omar and Rasheeda at
slave is quote a vehicle for the hopes
of millions of Muslims and others who
feel touched by her life story and for
the fears of those who feel threatened
by her now they're trying to make this
this big inspirational story and an
indictment of the West and all of these
things just look at these people like
Ilana Morris Somali immigrant gets
elected to Congress at the age of 36
what a wonderful country would do that
what an incredible country what other
country on earth in the history of the
world could such a thing happen I'll
wait name me any of course what a
wonderful that's a wonderful thing to
say about this country they're trying to
use it however as an indictment and it's
it is all it is not based on
reason we talked about this a little
yesterday with Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
often on the right you'll hear
conservatives say well we should point
out to the intersectional left that the
Islamic religion is harsh on gay people
or is harsh on women or it's illiberal
or it's intolerant or it calls for
non-believers to have their necks
chopped off or a god no it doesn't
matter you doesn't matter if you point
that out that's not what it's about it's
not about Islam
it's not about women's rights it's not
about women it's not about racial
minorities it's not about helping any of
those people
it's not about supporting any of those
things it's about a tech tacking Big
Daddy
it's about attacking the top of the
ideological ridiculous pyramid that they
have constructed in intersectionality
which is the man who is white who's
probably Christian who thinks that he's
a man who's straight he's a tree's
attracted to women it's all about going
after that one person logic be damned
it's not logical
you're not going to to attack them in
this way this is why it there was an
article that I was I did an interview
for the Washington Examiner and they
were asking what the best way to go
after the left ends in in this day and
age and the best way to do it is humor
that's the best way you're not gonna get
them and show them the error of their
ideological ways by just debating them
by just pointing out history or
philosophy or theology or whatever
you're not going to get them that way
but one thing that is irresistible is
humor you can't help but laugh even the
most humorless people if you hit their
funny bone the right way they can't help
but laugh laughing is an involuntary
response to to reality and we could go
on for hours and hours about what makes
something funny what theories of humor
are but to use just one example when you
see incongruous things when you see
juxtaposition of absurdity and reality
of fantasy and reality it does provoke
laughter if it's if it's delivered in
the right way this is the way that we
attack them this is the way that we hit
them on this because it they're so
ideologically far-gone they're so
enraptured with their own fantasy world
you're not gonna get them in an earnest
way you've got to make them laugh and
and we are going to get so much laughter
out of this new Congress I'm actually
fairly happy this is why it can't be so
upset nothing is really gonna change on
the legislative front you're gonna get
more investigations of Donald Trump okay
we we knew that was coming
you're gonna get threats of impeachment
you're gonna get all this kind of crazy
stuff you are going to see infighting
you were going to see craziness you are
gonna get 30-second Twitter video clips
you are gonna get great stuff from this
new Congress they're already fighting
there was a big move led by the farthest
left faction of the incoming
congressional class to attack the rules
being made by Nancy Pelosi herself it is
going to be a lot of fun enjoy it don't
complain this is just fine it's all I'm
like the bay or the little dog where
everything is on fire around him it's
fine it's gonna be fun
look at that fire around you and light
your cigar on it we're gonna have a good
time speaking of looking ahead to 2020
there is a new presidential endorsement
that's come around so Liz Warren makes
her really pathetic announcement she
does that really pathetic beer-swilling
a video that was going around the
internet she goes hello hello regular
people I'm a regular person glug glug
glug I'm Liz Warren a regular person
glug glug glug it was just pathetic and
everyone is mocking her candidacy Donald
Trump obviously sent out the daily wire
meme about it 1 1 xx xx Andrew Cuomo the
governor of New York has a different
idea for 2020 and I have to say kills me
to say it he's half right I think of all
the names that are out there I think Joe
Biden has the best case I think Joe
Biden has the best case because he
brings the most of the secret ingredient
ingredient you need to win for a
Democrat which is credibility you know
where this country is is they don't
believe anyone Trump was elected as a
rejection to the entire system they just
don't believe the Democrats I'm going to
do this I'm going to do
this I'm gonna do this you haven't done
anything and every idea you've come up
with has backfired and what have you
done to help me in my life you know you
don't hire an airline pilot who has
never flown a plane where is the
credibility in your argument Joe Biden
can say I was there okay there's not the
president but I was the second seat okay
okay this is actually half right it's
funny cuz Cuomo starts to undermine his
argument he says look you've got gonna
hire an airline pilot who hasn't flown a
plane like well Joe Biden hasn't well
yeah but he was there he was there he
was he was there he was in like row five
he was in Economy Plus comfort okay he
maybe he hasn't flown a plane but he
paid a hundred and fifty dollars more to
be an economy plus and he got a little
extra leg room and he got free booze on
the plane so okay it's a muddy argument
but he's making the case that Joe Biden
has a lot of experience and he does have
a lot of experience he was chairman of
the Senate Judiciary Committee senator
for a long time he ran for president
about 75,000 times vice-president under
Barack Obama fairly popular as vice
president that's true he points out that
Donald Trump was a rejection of the
system also true there the one of the
reasons there are many reasons why
Donald Trump won but one of the reasons
why he beat at 16 regular old
Republicans and beat out Hillary Clinton
is they were fed up with lying
politicians who talk like politicians
who look like Mitt Romney who sound like
Mitt Romney who turned around and
switched their positions and have no
ideological core like Mitt Romney who
stabbed their allies in the back like
Mitt Romney can you tell I'm still a
little upset about this MIT Romney
Washington Post op-ed yesterday just a
little bit but it was a rejection of
that you know Mitt Romney was our
previous GOP nominee and we looked
around at this guy and we said we don't
we said not him anything but could we
have the opposite of that please can
when we've gotten you get Donald Trump
and the general election turned out that
way too they said we don't need
Clinton's no more Clinton stop we don't
want you we want Donald Trump that's
true he was a rejection of the system
unfortunately Joe Biden is the system
he's been in the system now forever
andrew cuomo's right the democrats have
no credibility
what sort of credibility do they have
they they I mean what I'm trying to
think of it you can't think of a
negative that's the trouble what have
they done what was the legacy of the
Obama administration part of Obamacare
because even not even all of Obamacare
exists anymore the mandates gone the
central feature of the of Obamacare is
gone what what did the Obama
administration do it was like 8 years
just vanished vanished before my eyes
what is that me I mean what who cares
and they don't they no longer like the
Clinton administration because he was
too conservative and because he's been
accused of rape and because he's he was
a sexual predator so they don't like
that so where is what if they've done I
mean what credibility do Democrats have
over the last 30 years not very much so
you've got Joe Biden okay you've got
some credibility there and the
credibility is that he's got experience
the trouble is experience doesn't really
matter was Donald is Donald Trump
experienced in politics know what office
did Donald Trump hold before not nothing
even nope no office at all and
experience doesn't really seem to matter
to the voting public
they picked Trump over Hillary Hillary
way more experienced Trump one good
thing Trump won they picked Barack Obama
over John McCain McCain way more
experienced Barack Obama still won they
picked George Bush over Al Gore Al Gore
was more experienced he was in the
number two seat he was the vice
president before he ran for president in
2000 and they picked Bush and good thing
to push one obviously George HW Bush was
more experienced than Bill Clinton that
goes without saying Jimmy Carter was
more experienced than Ronald Reagan we
don't care about experience Richard
Nixon was much more experienced than
John F Kennedy
we actually died I think the experience
thing is just a total canard I mean it's
just a total force that it's one of
those things in politics that we think
should be true but it isn't true we
don't care if anything experience might
be a disadvantage in politics and so
that's really going against Joe Biden
he's also four years older than Trump
Trump is already not young to be the
president and so Biden's already that
much older and the big issue we were
talking about intersectionality Joe
Biden his big daddy he's a straight
white guy who's been in power forever
he's old and he just really is really
gonna be hard for the left which has put
all of its money on intersectionality to
then nominate and vote for a straight
white guy who's old it's just I can't
really see it happening I agree with
Cuomo Biden would be the best candidate
right now that the Democrats have but
they're not going to nominate him I just
don't I mean that may be Barack Obama
tries to come out and and convince
everybody to do it it's just gonna be
really hard they've set themselves up to
fail and they've set themselves up to
fail with their best candidate we've got
a lot more to get to the most disturbing
video I've seen in a very long time and
then of course the mailbag but first
you've got to go to daily wire.com it's
ten bucks a month 100 dollars for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Android Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you get to watch the
backstage and ask questions to the
backstage that's coming up today don't
miss it with Ben Shapiro and replevin
Alicia cross daily wire God came geremy
boring and little ol me will be ringing
in the New Year while drinking tumblers
have melted leftist snowflakes so be
sure to tune in as always only daily
where subscribers can't ask questions so
make sure to subscribe today and then
you can catch all of your delicious
snowflakes in the leftist tiers tumblr
and giddy up you're gonna need these
otherwise you will die in the Avalanche
brought up by the new Congress go to
daily wire.com we'll be right back with
both the mailbag and the most disturbing
video I've seen in a long time
so is this woman named Amelia bono and
she started a movement called the shout
your abortion movement this is a turn in
the left's ideological language some of
us are old enough to remember when
Hillary Clinton 2008 running for
president says abortion should be safe
legal and rare now of course this
doesn't make any sense if abortion is
morally similar to murder than it
shouldn't be legal if abortion is no
different than getting your tonsils
taken out then it shouldn't be rare but
this was her line and hypocrisy is the
tribute that Vice pays to virtue and at
least she was a big knowledge Engraving
to an abortion even if she's saying we
should have them anyway fast forward to
now you've got the shout your abortion
movement being pushed by this woman
Amelia Bono and she is as just released
this video of her talking to little
children about why abortion is great and
why logically and if you follow it to
the logical conclusion their parents
should have had the right to kill them
do you think that sometimes it's not
okay to have an abortion I want to say
if like if you're being reckless if
there's nothing wrong going on I don't
know I just don't agree
when you have an abortion what exactly
do you do to like have the abortion you
go to the doctor and they put this
little straw inside of your cervix and
then inside of your uterus and then they
just suck the pregnancy out and it was
like a crappy dentist appointment or
something it was just like ah this is
like a body thing that's kind of
uncomfortable but then it was over and I
felt really just grateful that I wasn't
pregnant anymore I felt really really
great can't you see how great I feel
Tibet that's why I'm I have to talk
about it all the time is because of how
great I feel and it's not that my soul
is being ripped to shreds from within me
no I feel great kids I feel great
don't you want to be like me that's what
you know there's this I can't believe
they actually included it in there they
included the reaction of a little girl
talking to this woman and you said
what's what happens in abortion she said
well you know you stick a tube in there
and you suck the pregnancy out what is
the pregnancy it's the baby of course
and she says suck the pregnancy out in
you and it cuts to the little girl my
little girl goes that yeah of course
that's what we all did are you actually
it's got pretty dark humor but you it
actually prompts laughter because you
see that the little kid has it right and
this woman is deluding herself to
pretend that abortion is okay with that
little kid has is something called the
wisdom of repugnance there are some
things that just the when you just look
at the sight of it something disgusting
something awful something grotesque a
dead body
whatever you look at it and you're just
immediately withdraw it's so disgusting
to you that's the wisdom of repugnance
and that little girl is showing that
when we're talking about killing a baby
in the womb which is abortion and I'm
not gonna attack this woman
Amelia Bono I mean she's she should put
out more videos it's the best
advertising the pro-life movement has
ever had also because this is clearly a
deeply disturbed woman we saw we did a
video on this show we played it a little
while ago of a woman who was at a
pro-abortion rally and she was talking
about how when she was about to kill her
baby she had this vision of the
baby singing a lullaby to her and then
she's sang the weird lullaby about how
it was okay for the mother to kill her
she talked about her religious views and
how death is not different from life and
it was really creepy it was really
creepy and sick and twisted and that's
what this woman has going on I mean
that's why if if you're confident in a
point of view you probably don't need to
go out and sit down with a bunch of
children and try to get little children
to affirm your point of view and fail at
it actually and not really because all
of the kids said well weren't you a
little reckless I mean maybe you
shouldn't you shouldn't do that maybe
that's not a great idea and so I really
feel for this woman it's it's pretty
sick and twisted stuff but this is the
logical conclusion when you wipe away
all of the euphemisms of this sucking
out the pregnancy the it's a weird
little body thing it's like an unfunded
test appointment when you take out all
of the euphemisms you can always judge
how true something is by how many
euphemisms and how much it's your
goodness to describe it
when you take all of that away what do
you have you have a woman trying to
justify two children why she killed a
child and and you look at the kids
reaction and they know it's wrong and
they can they know innately that it's
wrong intuitively that it's wrong and
she knows that it's wrong too and she's
trying to justify it with lies and she's
failing and I think she's probably
failing even to herself the lady doth
protest too much methinks
she's trying to wipe out that damned
spot like Lady Macbeth I don't know how
many more Shakespeare allusions I can
use she knows that is wrong it is
knowing at her it is keeping her up at
night and she can change her mind it's
not too late sometimes when people go
down paths of sin and paths of evil and
paths of terrible decisions they say I'm
so far gone I could never possibly come
back you can you could do it in two
seconds you have free will it's a new
day we live in time you can do it in two
seconds but it's hard for people to
admit that they're wrong it's hard for
people to turn around even though it's
totally open for them let's get to the
mailbag from Grant hi Michael I'm 25
years old and I've had intercourse with
two women in my life my current and my
ex girlfriend I ostensibly regret doing
so with my ex because I've recently come
back to serving God and Jesus in my life
and I plan on marrying my current
girlfriend of four years after I
graduate from university should I be
feeling regret for the first time with
my ex what is your stance on no
intercourse before marriage I'm deeply
in love with my current girlfriend we
talked about marrying each other often
love your work
thank you for expanding my knowledge
helping get me on the track to Jesus
PS came for Ben's stayed for Michael
yeah good man grant Cheers okay should
you regret having sex with your
ex-girlfriend do you do you regret it
I think you do in part you seemed to
import you I mean I can't tell you if
you regret something but you're writing
to me this is kind of bothering you okay
so you clearly were you're at it in port
but then you said use this word
ostensibly apparently it seems to be
that you ostensibly regret having sex
with your ex-girlfriend what do you mean
by that
I actually know exactly what you mean by
that you know I was an atheist for about
ten years and I know exactly what you
mean by the st. Agustin wrote but I'm
miserable young man supremely miserable
even in the very outset of my youth had
entreated chastity of you and said grant
me chastity and countenance II but not
yet Lord make me chaste but not yet what
you're saying is that in a spiritual and
intellectual way you'll regret having
sex with your ex-girlfriend because you
know that it's wrong and yet in a
physical way in a way that satisfies the
their very real passions that you feel
in your very real physical body you
don't regret it because it felt awesome
and you really liked it it was a lot of
fun that's what you're saying okay yeah
right that's that's my opinion
that's exactly right that does it the
fact that you enjoyed having sex with
your ex-girlfriend in a very physical
way does not change the fact that in an
intellectual way you regret having sex
because you realize it may have demean
certain relationships and it would have
been better if you had waited to have
sex and you it you might have used
somebody just for sex rather than for
some better relationship and it also
doesn't change the fact that
intellectually you know that it is
have sex outside of marriage doesn't
change that at all I don't know if it
should keep you up at night that is the
human condition we are always striving
against our flesh which is which has
appetites that our intellect doesn't
have so you did it and now you want to
get married and you know that that's
wrong okay life goes on
the one thing you should not do and you
should really seek to avoid but our
culture does it all the time is we say
my body desires one thing and so I need
to change my mind to agree with the
lusts of my body or else I'm a hypocrite
that doesn't make you a hypocrite
because you think it's wrong to have sex
outside of marriage and yet you had sex
with your ex-girlfriend it makes you a
human who's fallen and has desires and
can't always control his desires that
makes you human not a hypocrite now if
you're constantly going out and
carousing and doing it anyway then you
know if you make a habit of it then then
you you would be a hypocrite but it
would be far far worse to change your
mind and say no because I had sex before
marriage it's okay to have sex before
marriage or outside of marriage that
would be the wrong thing and that would
be the most dishonest thing because
something tells me that your intellect
just thinking more clearly than you know
a young man's body speaking from
experience that doesn't young men's
bodies don't always think in the
clearest kind of way from Eric dear
Michael aka dapper Lib triggering droll
can you explain the key differences
between conservatism and as Dave Rubin
would say classical liberalism yes this
is a excellent question well done this
is confusing because in the United
States conservatives largely seek to
preserve a classically liberal tradition
and and the classical liberals would
call these universal truths I as a
conservative would not call these
necessarily universal truths I would
call it a classically liberal tradition
the difference here is that
conservatives like Alexander Hamilton or
like Edmund Burke while defending a
classically liberal tradition remain
skeptical of those universal truths and
prefer a series of trial and error
whereas classical liberals are so
enthusiastic about it and they they are
they embrace it
early this I think would be a difference
it's a subtle difference but a major one
classical liberals tend to talk about
the Enlightenment
as if history began in the late 17th
century history began just after Thomas
Hobbes and all of history that matters
has happened in the modern era they are
thoroughly modern whereas conservatives
think there's a lot more to history into
the world than that there's a lot more
than just John Locke John Locke is not
the be-all and end-all of political
philosophy we've had many more things
that matter institutions matter this is
another difference between the classical
liberal and the conservative the
classical liberal tends to always speak
in rationalist terms
he's always standing for something and
it's only about principles usually
universal principles and in institutions
be damned and who cares about candidates
or elections or dates or times or
political parties or that none of that
matters all that matters are the
ethereal rationalist abstractions and
ideologies that stand up here and they
just kind of float in the air and
whenever you try to touch them you
corrupt them whereas the conservative
would say hey buddy look down here come
here
come back to reality there are
institutions that transmit these ideas
and we can arrive at some of the same
conclusions classical liberals and
conservatives are right especially in
America arrive at many many of the same
conclusions but we do so because we say
these ideas have been transmitted
through time through the tradition
through constant trial and error on the
local level on the state level on the
federal level in religious institutions
in the military in all everywhere all
around the culture and and they have
been tested they've been tried they've
been refined and they have lasted and
they've endured and perhaps they've
endured for a reason and therefore we
can support the idea but we remain
skeptical of pure rationalist
abstractions you can tell which side of
this I come down on I come down on the
conservative side not the classical
liberal side but I think that a lot of
the anti-trump stuff this the schism on
the right between the nevertrump errs
and the people who either reluctantly or
enthusiastically embrace Trump I think
it's about this argument because you a
lot of classical liberals will tell you
that all that matters the only there's
there's no difference but
conservatism in classical liberalism but
there is you'll hear some people say I'm
a conservative because I'm a liberal I'm
a real liberal Bill Kristol who is the
probably the leading nevertrump er says
we should rename the Republican Party
the Liberal Party and we should just
have a Liberal Party that's fine for
liberals for classical liberals but for
those of us who think that history began
before the late 17th and 18th century
who would like other ideas who have
other senses of things who don't want to
just float in the abstract who like
institutions who like the ideas that are
embodied in them who like culture who
like the things that can't be written
down in a philosophy textbook that's not
going to cut it and and we're not
totally married to rationalism and so I
I endorse conservative thought over
classically liberal thought but it's
confusing in America because when you
just look on the surface it's very often
almost the same thing dave rubin and i
if you look at precise political issues
don't disagree on too much we disagree
on some things but not probably we agree
on more than we disagree on but when you
look at the foundations of those
thoughts they're probably quite
different from mary hey michael is a
catholic why do you believe in the death
penalty
don't you agree with the Catholic
catechism updated version even before
Francis that says it is immoral unless
in extreme circumstances in which the
public is at risk if the person is not
killed it asked if GL systems are
insufficient etc no not at all and the
Catechism doesn't say that the Catechism
even still refuses to say that the death
penalty is intrinsically evil Pope
Francis has all but said that he said
that it's an attack on the inviolability
of the dignity of the human person or
some such language but that isn't true
that's just wrong it is certainly the
tradition of all of Christendom that the
death penalty is perfectly fine and
defended st. Paul defends it in his
letters it is it's defended in the
Gospels as the civil authority having
civil authority is defended in the
Gospels in fact our salvation comes
through the crucifixion which is an
example of the death penalty being
instituted by a civil authority Thomas
Aquinas defends the
the church fathers defend this endlessly
the the point I'll make on this is that
all shallows are clear so you a lot of
people look today and they say oh the
death death penalty seems bad and a
couple Pope's one Pope has said it's
really really bad so therefore it's bad
no it goes a little deeper than then you
have to think a little bit more deeply
all shallows are clear and profound
things are murky and a little more
complicated sometimes but that's their
nature from Brett Oh Kofi Fei sensei
Oh sukhothai sense it in my endless
debates with a family member of mine who
identifies as a Democratic Socialist I
stumbled upon a hurdle I cannot quite
clear the military police and border
security are all socialist programs and
if we do not have a problem with these
socialized programs and more than that
we love them then why am I so staunchly
opposed to the socialist healthcare and
socialism in general thanks Mike well I
wouldn't call them socialist they're for
the common defense everything you name
is for the common defense or military a
border security law enforcement and
that's the purpose of the government we
have a government to defend law and
order to end to defend us from threats
outside and threats inside that's and
they do it well but there are mistakes
you know it's the left constantly is
talking about how awful the military is
how awful the police are they want to
demilitarize the police meaning they
want the police to be even less like the
military so it's a little disingenuous
for them to then come around and say how
great the military and the police or the
point is that when you give the
government that power it's very hard to
get it back you can't really take it
back from them and and the police and
the military make mistakes too I mean we
give them that power and they do a
wonderful job for us and they protect us
and they defend our liberty but we only
want to give the government the amount
of power that is minimum to protect us
and to protect our Liberty and to
protect our civilization why would we
give them any more than that the
government isn't very good at doing
things the government isn't very good at
managing huge bureaucracies and huge
power on the national scale especially
can really corrupt people so if you give
the government control over your health
care all of a sudden on in a very
practical way you're gonna see quality
go down and the costs go up but in a
spiritual way and in a in a matter of
political rights you're go
to see that you're not gonna have as
much control over your body over your
family over your Liberty over your life
you're going to have like in England
you're gonna have parents begging to
take their little baby and get medical
care outside of the UK the Pope
interjecting on the baby's behalf and
saying bring him to this hospital the
United States saying bring him to this
hospital and the government saying no we
own your baby we own your life deal with
it you gave us that power that's why you
have to stay away from socialism one
more before we go from Augustine Michael
I have been talking to a girl for a
while now we're finally ready to go on
our first date we've not yet discussed
politics so I was curious of how you
brought up the topic with sweet little
ELISA and any other dating tips you have
any other dating tips you have well when
I first met sweet little ELISA I was 11
years old so it didn't it didn't come up
right away I mean I did come out of the
womb smoking a cigar and reading Edmund
Burke so there is that parting my hair
but it didn't come up right away no we
talked about other things certainly when
we were 12 and politics comes up when
you talk and you talk about culture and
you talk about personal things you're
talking about whatever but I never made
a point about it I wouldn't I wouldn't
worry about it I mean we here's here's
here's my main advice on dating you
should enjoy it it's a very fun it is a
great pleasure and privilege to be in
the company of a woman having a drink
having a meal what do you know going son
a walk so if this is a wonderful thing
this is one of the great joys of life
enjoy it talk to her find out what she
thinks
find out what she or her points of view
make her laugh a little bit show her
something she hasn't seen that could be
taken in a very bad way I'm talking
about a sunset or something be really
you know be romantic be charming enjoy
if you're not enjoying the date she's
not enjoying the date I promise you that
and don't make it it's not a job
interview
you're not like okay are you gonna be my
wife are we gonna get married tomorrow
okay do you check this box of it no come
on man it's she's a human being she's a
woman this is one of the great
consolations of life enjoy it have a
good time if you don't let me know how
it goes then we're all try to give you
more advice all right that's our show
we've got a backstage coming up so I got
to get out of here but tune in for that
it's gonna be a lot of fun in the
meantime I'm Michael nose this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you